Daniel is with us in Virginia hey Daniel
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
it's a pleasure to talk to you know
YouTube I know I have a feeling of what
you're gonna say but I just wanted to
call to get confirmation and have you
say it but um to give the rundown we've
been following you for since like
October of last year we got the saving
of fun and I currently have two jobs
both of those jobs bringing in two
hundred and sixty thousand a year my
wife makes one thirty a year the problem
is is that and um we have like between
credit cards student loans all of that
we're at like four hundred K right now
and we're trying to Chunkin a deed Chuck
chucking it down chucking it down the
the problem is is I'm more like
aggressively financially putting into
the debt then then my wife is um and the
reason I found that out is because I saw
her bank statement lying around she
didn't and she still doesn't know that
I've seen it and she has like twenty
thousand in her account so she's kind of
been lying to me about how much money
that she can put in towards the debt
right now based off of the snowball her
student loans are next in line because
she doesn't have any of her loans
consolidated but I do know Mize is a
huge a huge loan versus pers being like
onesie twosie
how long you guys still married um six
years you want to stay married yeah
you're gonna stop doing this it's not
working you gonna kill each other man
you're you're at you're treating your
wife like she's a roommate she's not
your roommate when you went down the
aisle you went dun dun dun
the preacher didn't say and now you are
roommates you go have your checking
account and you have your loans and you
go have your checking account and you
have your loans you have your income and
she has her income that is not what the
preacher said the preacher said and now
you are one unto thee all my worldly
goods I pledge you need to combine all
of your finances combine all of your
accounts and learn to work together
instead of standing off in two separate
bedrooms in each into the house yelling
at each other you gonna kill each other
man this is this is the kind of crap
right here that causes divorces over
money you need to sit down together and
share goals and shared money we have an
income you're French now baby oui oui
we have an income we have debt we have a
budget we have a plan that we are both
in a grey tone we have a bunch of debt
and we have a bunch of income and we're
gonna fix this crap